what's up Instagram
hi guys like in story so far Instagram
stories
and no need to fight to names
yes
we said look brands have gotta be
storytellers Jesus there so we took this
different angle and that was it so
that's where this cake that's when I was
there I I got the Sea Shepherd's up
thank you so much
what's your name Alex nice to meet you
thanks for saying hello yeah of course
if somebody sits the other day and that
it was the facts of the journey so and I
really realized this is not the carrot
she's new here the camera was a carrot
and if you put a carrot in front of the
ioniq run for a rule for the count yeah
what I've realized is the carrots never
get anyplace okay if you work for
something how did they say so the other
thing is if I ever got the carrot and I
go look for another one episode so the
destination is not a camera hopefully
sense that it's the journey it is the
second lady is dragon because I don't
want the carrot I want the cucumber all
hands on deck to build out our CD
capabilities I feel like
to make it happen so we won't have we're
gonna leave 150 million a media spend on
yep yep yep just open
all right all right brother nice to meet
you d-roc how you doing very well good
man
extremely well so how long has this been
in the making I started building it two
years ago we opened a little over your a
little over a year ago yes so it's a
appointment-only
my workspace and so a kind of place in
multiple roles so we do all of our aging
and creating and stuff here as well it's
[ __ ] rad and we do dinners out here
and live music and yeah let's go
so this place giving clients
sort of all walks of life in the country
it just kind of gives a pigeon at what
we can do so we create and sort of build
things from small to large scale a
multitude that the platform is really
first what is it you know it's been kind
of word of mouth so you know people are
slowly kind of finding out about what we
do so how do you frame your company is
it a maker yeah I mean it's bit of a
bakery right so how many like how many
yeah have three people so when you get
into this kind of scale you're just
tapping into people to help you go I do
it all I mean like I mean real on the
revenue for instance I brought into a
Brendan two extra people to just for
like right laboring things as far as
like a gene and so forth Michael make
this [ __ ] giraffe this game from the
Gambino family so I got this cottage so
awesome yeah
all the readies aware that we most of
our clients as we build relationships
with them it goes full tailor
so they come in we do full fittings and
so what is that is this literally spat
as a spec for you to look at or just
there's a human come in here and buy
like a person buys it yeah is everything
like sub right so somebody comes in is
like I love this all right please please
tell us please tell me the pricing comes
from your head on the spot oh it's
always that way oh hi doc you know
garage sales are my favorite thing on
earth so so like this is clearly but
like but if I'm like is it literally
like you know how much were there and
you're like that's [ __ ] the best yeah
trying to tell the whole real like
American story
such an intense transition right
Oh
I first start getting to that
when I started jumpsuit you know I had
this idea of taking other people's
brands that point no one was thinking
that but it exists and I was a critic
they look basically became the vintage
see you know I was like I want to make a
DA that feels like it's old what seemed
weird back that you don't see ya now of
course I want to I want to I want people
to know what this is I just I just need
to have a flow through I want two or
three times a year I want to do a real
wine event that matters and this is the
place to do it
yeah cool congratulations this is really
I'm you know I'm sure you're tired of
hearing it but it is what it is that it
is that word dude I'm gonna get you into
this place
John John Dorian great to meet you it's
it's a retail store okay we're like no
map
dude never like search I like so far
underground dude it's one of the most
interesting places I've been to in my
life great attack you'll see you know
what you'll see a lot of [ __ ] I'm gonna
put a ton of you I know it's it's secret
but he's about to not make it secret
world right and then understanding the
economics of to both functioning parties
I think is they can't is the question
that needs to get answered right like is
it 200 salary and 5% carry and then
do you recollect one day I'll get one of
these
let's go
I'll figure out
yep
thank you what for for thank you
gary vaynerchuk hi nice to meet you
right speaking easy awesome attic like
that was my first event for my first
book yeah it was for a crush it dude you
weren't kidding
you still haven't huh yeah I think we
both look better I definitely do you do
- yeah that's awesome
thank you for the luck I can write about
you I found them they were here the
whole time
awesome hey how are you nine ten eleven
even though I could talk alright it's
good to see David yeah I was there can I
fight his way end so I was like they
have a listener tonight of seats and I
got three I did really well got it hey
there's a real pleasure to me man we do
it up did a picture yes for sure
awesome big thank you say man say well
yeah I'm sure I'll be seeing you now
is real this is Gary Vaynerchuk well I
saw your number in the comments and I
said I've got 1800s in a second so why
don't I call and say thank you for
paying attention to some of my stuff and
wish you well and hope everything's
awesome for me let's grant follow your
finest things are working out thank you
very much you're welcome I hope you have
a great evening thank you take care of
life
so funny the next comment is doing the
right thing is always the right